troisième tentative pour arnaud
montebourg après 2012 et 2017 l'ancien
ministre de l'économie se lancent une
nouvelle fois dans la course à l'elysée
cette fois pas de primaires socialistes
pour lui il en était pourtant l'un de
ses plus fervents défenseurs en 2009
tous les pays qui ont organisé ça au
chili la grèce l'italie les états unis
ont eu des succès considérables des
millions de citoyens sont venus
participer à la fois la discussion du
projet et c'est une manière de
démocratiser l'élection présidentielle
un an plus tard en octobre 2010 il se
déclare candidat à ces primaires lors de
sa campagne montebourg a sa méthode bien
à lui
on y va on a cinq minutes on peut boire
une bière monteux bourse va être un
candidat proche des gens il multiplie
les rencontres parcourt la france dans
la rue il fait le show et se démarque de
ses concurrents grâce au stand up un
moyen de communication venue des états
unis c'est une campagne à l'américaine
au cul du camion voilà un c'est à dire
que on pas voir les gens discutent sans
ambages on donne notre je donne mes
convictions on n'est pas obligé d'être
d'accord malgré ses efforts arnaud
montebourg échouent aux primaires il
termine derrière françois hollande et
martine aubry martine aubry françois
hollande s'était rené blanc blanc bonnet
vous pouvez choisir je n'ai pas employé
le mot de bonnet mais vous n'avez pas
tout à fait tort en 2014 il se retire de
la vie politique avant de revenir en
août 2016 quelques mois avant l'élection
présidentielle
je suis revenu pour agir on m'engager et
cette fois pour réussir depuis son fief
de saône et loire il se déclare candidat
à la présidentielle de 2017 mais rien
concernant sa participation aux
primaires de la gauche ira ira pas il
donne sa réponse au journal de tf1 le 2
octobre 2016 est ce que vous allez
participer à cette primaire socialiste
oui j'ai décidé d'inscrire ma
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
de 2017 dans le cadre des primaires de
la gauche pour sa campagne arnaud
montebourg utilisent les mêmes outils de
communication qu'en 2011
on va faire le métier dans la rue il se
met encore en scène l'installation est
sommaire quelques projecteurs un micro
et surtout du show du show et encore du
show l'on fait des campagnes sans argent
et c'est mieux parce qu on est avec les
gens fouet la politique au cul du camion
c'est un peu ça vous faites attention
vous allez tomber nouvelle désillusion
pour arnaud montebourg il échoue encore
une fois aux primaires du ps derrière
benoît hamon et manuel valls cette année
il se lance pour la troisième fois dans
la course à l'elysée cette fois sans
passer par la case primaire stains de
given by voilà n'abandonne pas le combat